[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économique sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines nous sommes sur la
zone d'activités trapel en cours plus
précisément au sein de l'entreprise
match event c'est un spécialiste de
l'audiovisuel prestation de sons de
lumières de vidéos cette société a
souffert durant la crise sanitaire mais
l'heure est à la relance nous verrons
comment match event vie la reprise de
l'activité dans le secteur de
l'événementiel
c'est ce que je vous propose de
découvrir dans ce 25e numéro du sky et
co 12 millions d'euros c'est le montant
du plan france relance déployés sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
depuis septembre 2020 entreprises
collectivités et associations plusieurs
bénéficiaires le bilan dans cette
édition le secteur de l'événementiel
reprend des couleurs c'est le cas de
match event entreprise spécialisée dans
l'audiovisuel à elancourt enfin
rencontre avec élise luton ski elle suit
le programme entrepreneuriat pour tous
organisé par saint quentin en yvelines
son objectif créer sa société une future
vie d'entrepreneur il ya un an le
gouvernement lancer le déploiement du
plan france relancé dans les yvelines
sur une année plus de 500 millions ont
été engagés sur trois thématiques
l'écologie la compétitivité et la
cohésion des territoires focus sur le
déploiement de ce programme sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
dans ce décryptage
[Musique]
j'attends
bon sang
[Musique]
ça y est vous le voyez autour de moi le
matériel de sons de lumières de vidéo
ressort des armoires de match event
cette entreprise spécialisée dans
l'organisation d'événements sportifs ou
culturels en tout cas dans la captation
techniques de ces événements et pour en
parler de cette reprise d'activité nous
sommes avec jean françois lienart le
cofondateur de maxime bonjour bonjour
nicolas
bon
alors avant de parler de la reprise on
va parler du bilan de cette crise
sanitaire le secteur de l'événementiel a
été frappé par cette crise comment vous
l'avez vécu ici un match event alors
c'était très dur parce que ça a été un
arrêt brutal c'était vraiment du jour au
lendemain on se remémore le mois de mars
2020 ça a été immédiat total en l'espace
de quinze jours tout s'est arrêté il a
fallu trouver des solutions donc pour
les collaborateurs ça tout de suite
était la mise en place du chômage
partiel et ça c'est quelque chose qui a
bien fonctionné dans notre domaine
d'activité et ensuite on a cherché des
solutions vous dire c'est pas possible
comme on reste sans rien faire del arte
le retour du confinement au mois de mai
2000 va on a eu l'idée de monter ici
vous envoyer encore les restes ici d'un
studio d'un studio digital on s'est dit
notre matériel et l'aïd or les clients
ont besoin de communiquer on va tenter
quelque chose on va tenter de faire
venir ici à elancourt dans notre dépôt
on a créé on a tout le matériel sur
place on s'est dit bon on ne peut pas
louer aussi cher que si on était un
événement donc proposer à nos clients de
venir communiquer à travers l'outil
qu'on connait tous cependant le
confinement et pendant ces deux années
qui la visioconférence ou le streaming
et on a créé des événements digitaux
vous avez chiffré la perte que vous avez
c'est très simple c'est un bilan par le
chiffre d'affaires c'est moins 50% qu'il
doit faire et là avec cette reprise
d'activité comment vous la vivez cette
reprise d'activité alors elle est un
petit peu elle se ressent un petit peu
comme l'arrêt elle est aussi brutal qui
a été l'arrêt c'est dire que les clients
se sont cherchés les annonceurs qui sont
et les agences qui sont nos clients
principaux mettre du temps à se décider
et d'un seul coup on sent qu'il ya une
volonté en ce moment de bain de se
réunir parce que tout ce qui est
sanitaire était un petit peu allégés on
a le droit de se réunir à nouveau on a
le droit de refaire des salles donc ça
donne un petit peu un élan à tout ceci
malheureusement c'est sur les chapeaux
de roue s'est tout de suite on off et
l'image qu'on voit derrière nous c'est
ça en fait voilà la zone exactement et
dans la zone de préparation et de est de
retour donc c'est assez de matériel qui
va partir le matériel qui rend très
saine il ya déjà été checkés et rentrer
et on commence à avoir de nouveaux enfin
des poids lourds qui partent avec du
matériel avec de l'humain et avec des
clients qui sont là physiquement
l'humain c'est essentiel dans votre
métier qu'est quel élément quel type de
métier aujourd'hui vous recherchez
quelles compétences vous recherchez
aujourd'hui sur le marché du travail
alors pour répondre à la demande
croissante
on cherche une assistante comptable
parce que ben c'est reparti et c'est
important pour nous on cherche en
logistique 1 chauffeur poids lourd on
cherche un préparateur mettre deux
préparateurs de commande ici au niveau
des installations c'est assez ceux qui
préparent tout le matériel qui le
tchèque qui vérifie que ça fonctionne
pour qu'il parte en événements on
cherche qu on appelle des régisseurs qui
sont pour nous aussi des chargés
d'affaires c'est ce qu'ils vont faire
l'interface technique entre le
commercial et
et la partie technique ou à la partie
n'est pas seul un seul interlocuteur à
ce niveau là pour nos clients et on
recherche aussi des fonctions
commerciales parce que bon on peut pas
se permettre de s'endormir sur nos
lauriers même si société qui marche bien
il faut aller chercher du new business
il faut aller chercher des jeunes
talents et on est en recrutement sur ce
genre de sur ce type de poste là merci
jean françois lienart merci nicolas
cofondateur de match event et justement
on va aller tout de suite rejoindre
corinne gibourdel qui elle a été
recrutée en 2019 via un événement
organisé par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines sky emploi en piste
au vélodrome nation
[Musique]
et
c'est la responsable communication et
création chez match event corinne
gibourdel bonjour bonjour
alors donc comme je voulais dit vous
occuper de la communication de la
création vous avez été embauchés en 2010
9 via l'événement sky emploi en piste
c'est un événement organisé par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines son principe une journée de job
dating au vélodrome national des ja
première question comment vous vous
sentez en tant que salarié d'une
entreprise du secteur de l'événementiel
aujourd'hui eh bien écoutez on a
beaucoup d'énergie non parce qu'il nous
en faut pour cette rentrée donc on est
plein d'énergie on est plein d'espoir
et on a beaucoup d'idées à mettre en
place sur les années à venir on vient de
le voir avec jean françois lienart vous
avez été frappés par la crise sanitaire
un secteur événementiel vraiment touchée
par la crise sanitaire vous comment vous
l'avez vécu cette crise sanitaire en
tant que salarié alors d'abord la
surprise évidemment comme tout le monde
tout s'arrête du jour au lendemain ce
que disait je me souvienne à
tous tous les tournages s'arrête le
monde s'écroule quelques pas et en même
temps où on peut pas nous se permettre
d'arrêter donc on est obligé de
continuer et c'est aussi la période sur
laquelle on va pouvoir se remettre en
question on va pouvoir entre guillemets
prendre le temps de se poser les
questions qu'on n'avait pas forcément le
temps de se poser ah bon alors on l'a vu
avec jean françois lienart vous avez des
besoins en recrutements je les ai dit au
début de l'entretien vous avez été
embauchés via l'événement sky emploi
fait sa rentrée sky emploi en piste et
justement sky emploi fait sa rentrée le
21 octobre prochain match event y
participent une journée de job dating en
virtuel est-ce que vous avez des
conseils à donner aux téléspectateurs
qui souhaitent postuler à mach event et
comment vous sentiez-vous à l'époque à
ce moment là alors moi je je ne
m'attendais pas à rencontrer mon futur
employeur pour être tout à fait franc je
l'étais indépendante et je venais pour
rencontrer les entreprises pour pouvoir
retravailler avec eux mais sous forme
plutôt de mission et puis il ya eu cette
rencontre avec beaucoup de points
communs et puis une réelle envie d'aller
d'aller plus loin voilà donc c'est comme
ça qu'on a qu'on a signé ensemble donc
ceux des téléspectateurs qui sont
intéressés par cet événement quels
conseils vous pouvez leur donner
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui même
beaucoup de beaucoup d'ouverture
d'esprit beaucoup de dynamisme je pense
que ça chez match l'énergie c'est
vraiment le le point commun de tous nos
métiers on a beaucoup de métier mais ils
sont tous il demande beaucoup de
beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup d'ouverture
beaucoup d' écoute le sens aussi du
service client c'est très important
que ce soit au niveau du conseil
clientèle pour les pour les chargés de
projet pour les assistant rh au niveau
de l'un terne mais également les
techniciens parce que pas parce qu'ils
sont ils sont eux mêmes aussi en contact
avec nos clients et tout ça forme un
ensemble et merci corinne gibourdel
merci je rappelle que vous êtes la
responsable communication et création
chez match yves intello sky échos se
poursuit dans cette entreprise elles ont
suivi le cursus de l'entrepreneuriat
pour tous avec l'association les
déterminer élise le top ski et émail ou
n'en veulent devenir entrepreneurs
accompagnés par le ski cube ses deux
aînés mountain de 23 ans veulent créer
leur société baptisée emelyne skin un
salon de soins de la peau avec une
technologie particulière c'est la
séquence ma vie d'entrepreneur avec
élise luton ski bonjour je m'appelle
ellis du times qui j'ai 23 ans et
j'habite à montigny-le-bretonneux dans
les yvelines je suis préparatrice en
pharmacie de formation et j'ai également
un bts management des unités
commerciales
donc mon projet aujourd'hui c'est
d'ouvrir un institut de soins de la peau
dans les divines de préférence
[Musique]
je suis accompagné de mon associé qui se
nomme émail ou non on aimerait proposer
de nombreux soins de la peau grâce à une
nouvelle technologie qui vient
directement des états unis et qui se
nomme hydra faciale notre nouvelle
technologie consiste à nettoyer en
profondeur la peau et à la reid rester
sur du long terme
[Musique]
pendant la période de covin avec mon
associé ont remarqué que les femmes
avaient du mal à trouver leur routine
adaptée à leur type de peau et n'étaient
pas toujours satisfaite du coup on a
souhaité trouver une idée ou une
nouvelle technologie pour justement
répondre aux besoins de notre clientèle
c'est un peu d'excitation le ce
challenge j'aime / surmonter mes
objectifs du coup
c'était ça mon objectif travailler pour
soi aussi
[Musique]
les déterminés nous ont permis d'étudier
l'étude de marché de cibler notre
clientèle est également de créer notre
business plan idéal ce qui nous manque
aujourd'hui pour notre projet c'est
d'être accompagnés sur tout ce qui est
statut juridique sur les locaux et
également sur les plans de financement
[Musique]
on a dù de nombreux objectifs tout
d'abord respecter l'ouverture de mme et
2022 puis par la suite fidéliser notre
clientèle et faire notre clientèle et
notre objectif sur du long terme ce
serait également d'ouvrir un second
institut dans le sud de la france c'est
la fin de ce numéro merci de l'avoir
suivi une émission que vous pouvez
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
ou sur l'application mobile à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]